I thank you very much for being on the
program good morning Sophie good morning
now I appreciate it might feel slightly
strange starting a pre-budget interview
talking about tweets from Gary lineker
but it has spiraled into a foreground
crisis for the BBC do you think he needs
to apologize
well I personally profoundly disagree
with the comments that he made
um but I think what this shows and
indeed the related debate about the BBC
Chairman's appointment and we should
wait until the investigation is
completely independent investigation
before passing judgment on that is that
impartiality at the BBC is really
important the reason that it is a great
National Institution that we all
treasure so much is because it is
respected for impartiality so we need to
make sure that what comes out of this is
that people's confidence in the
impartiality of the BBC is restored so
you think that it's been compromised by
this no and I don't think it's for me
I'm one of the people by the way who the
BBC scrutinize
um and as do you in in your show and so
it's not for me to tell the BBC how to
do that but I think what this has shown
is how important the BBC is to all of us
and the central thing that people want
to know is that you know there isn't any
kind of political agenda in the way the
BBC goes about its business which I'm
not saying there is
but that is the confidence people need
to have but that's the point isn't it
because you talk about the confidence
and impartiality but I can't help
wondering if what we've seen has led
people to question the BBC's
Independence which is also very
important as well you mentioned of
course Richard Sharp the chairman of the
BBC who failed to declare his role in
facilitating an 800 000 pound loan to
Boris Johnson you say that you want to
keep out of the Gary lineker debate and
it's for the BBC but we're only in this
position because MPS like yourself
swella bravaman Robert generic other
conservative Adventures have come out
very strongly to criticize Gary Lincoln
and now you're just trying to wash your
hands of it well I think that BBC and
Independence really does matter for the
country and that's why I think it's
important that we let the BBC sort out
these problems but what I want to see is
the outcome is trust be maintained in
what is a very very important
institution when it comes to an election
we are very lucky to be in a country
where we have an organization that is an
independent Arbiter of the truth so that
people can find out the facts and then
make their judgment about which party to
vote for that's something very precious
do you think that's what we want to make
sure that we protect do you think the
current BBC leadership is seen as too
close to the party of government well I
don't think it's for me to make those
judgments I think that if we believe the
BBC should be independent which I do if
we believe in BBC and partiality which I
do then we have to let the BBC resolve
these issues I guess one of the reasons
people feel strongly about impartiality
is because Gary lineker has paid an
awful lot of taxpayers money
do you think that the funding model of
the BBC should be looked at
well I think we always need to keep up
with the times and you know we're in a
world where funding models for all
broadcasting is changing with you know
the Advent of streaming for example
um but do I believe in a taxpayer-funded
broadcaster uh that is able to
for example be one of the most respected
news gatherers in the world yes I do I
think it's very important for the
country and actually very important for
the world so I think we have something
very precious with the BBC that's why
we're we're talking about it even though
you're a competitor of the bbcs because
it's very important to all of us and I
think what we want to come out of this
is people feeling confident that the BBC
is on the right track when it comes to
Independence impartiality all these
things that really matter well if all
that matters you previously said that
Gary lineker should apologize do you
still think that well I don't agree with
his comments
uh you know I personally think that he
was wrong to say what he said but I
don't think it's for me to decide
as I say I I don't agree with what he
said I I as a government we want to get
on with solving uh the issue of illegal
migration partly because I'm very proud
we're one of the most open and tolerant
countries in the world when it comes to
Legal migration but if you believe in
BBC Independence then it's not for the
chancellor or any other government
minister to say how these issues are
resolved growing back then from the call
for the apology it feels like
um now I don't want to waste time
rattling through a list of possible
measures that might be in the budget you
telling me you can't talk about them
frustrating for me frustrating for you
frustrating for our viewers as well so
what in Broad terms should we expect
from your budget well I am a
conservative who believes in the virtue
of work I am incredibly proud of the
fact that because we've reduced taxes on
the lowest paid change the welfare
system introduced the national living
wage someone who is on benefit and out
of work
will make an extra seven and a half to
ten thousand pounds if they get a job
full time on the national living wage
and that's one of the reasons why
unemployment has halved since we've been
in power but we still have over a
million vacancies in the economy and the
brexit decision was a choice the right
choice in my judgment to say we
shouldn't fill those vacancies from
unlimited migration we need to break
down the barriers that stop people here
in the UK from working whether that's
parents who have obstacles because of
child care costs whether it's older
people who feel they need to retire
earlier than they might perhaps want to
whether it's long-term sick who find
there are barriers to working we need to
break down those barriers and this is a
budget in which I will be systematically
going through all the areas where there
are barriers that stop people working
who want to so that we can help people
get back to work fill those vacancies
for our business the problem is is hard
to get people back to work if they don't
have to isn't it if you're taking an
early retirement and you can afford to
do it why would you leave the golf
course and go back to work and also I
understand that there are real barriers
for some parents going back to work many
people it's a choice that they want to
spend more time with the young family
surely the easiest way to fill those
vacancies if we're real is by
immigration well I think our choice is
not to do that why not um because that
was the decision in the brexit
referendum
control over borders and you could
decide to relax certain immigration
rules to fill certain vacancies can you
controlled legal migration but not
filling every vacancy in our businesses
with uncontrolled migration and that was
the decision we took by leaving the
single Market
we fully respect the choice of people
who don't wish to work this isn't about
changing that choice but there are lots
of people let me give you an example
there are 700 000 parents on low pay on
Universal Credit who have a child Under
12 and they aren't able to work because
of the high cost of child care now we're
looking at whether we can remove some of
those barriers for example by paying
them their child care in advance not in
arrears looking at the level of support
that we give them and those are families
that would really benefit if the mum or
the dad was able to get back into work
that's removing a barrier that's
stopping people participating in the
labor force I think that's a good thing
some people on your own side are getting
a bit Twitchy about the level of
Taxation shall we say Corporation taxes
due to rise from 19 to 25 when you ran
to be party leader this is what you told
me on corporation tax you said I'm also
someone who doesn't think we shouldn't
just stop the corporation tax Rises I
think we should cut them so that the
lowest in Europe and North America I
think we should cut it to 15 are you
really going to be the chancellor who
puts it up to 25 what happened to that
Jeremy Hunt well it's the same Jeremy
Hunt that's with you now and I still
want us to have the most competitive
business taxes anywhere in the world
look I am a conservative who believes in
a low tax economy I'm incredibly proud
of the fact that under successive
conservative governments we've reduced
taxes so that for the first time in our
history you can earn a thousand pounds a
month without paying a penny of tax or
National Insurance that's by the way
that is one of the reasons why we've
lifted 2 million people out of absolute
poverty after housing after housing
costs that's including half a million
children so it's a it's a very very big
deal that we've done that for businesses
we need to encourage investment
investment by companies from overseas
coming into the UK investment by
companies at home that's how we'll close
our productivity Gap but I also have to
be responsible with public finances
we're not going to do what the last
Labor government did and run out of
money businesses need the stability that
comes from being responsible so we will
get there gradually but there we will
but let's look at the tax level shall we
because if you look at the current tax
burden you can see here it's projected
to hit
highest level since the 1960s I'm just
trying to get my head around the fact
that you know you say you believe in low
taxes you're a chancellor who run for
the leadership saying he was going to
cut corporation tax and now this is a
situation you are presiding over with
the economy I mean it takes a certain
amount of mental gymnastics to get there
well look at where that graph starts to
go up we had a global pandemic we've had
an energy crisis I'm actually very proud
of the fact that we're a society which
does believe in having a safety net and
despite the fact that our GDP fell by 20
at one point during the pandemic we
still kept unemployment low we haven't
seen thousands of people thrown onto the
Dole because we stepped in but that
costs money and I think it was right
that we responded in the way we did when
we did and because we have to be
responsible with our public finances yes
we are having to put taxes up
temporarily but the path we're going on
look at our track record bringing down
taxes on the low lowest paid in the
Autumn statement record is a tax
abundance
well I've just told you the first time
you don't pay a penny of tax or National
Insurance on the first thousand pounds
you earn every month uh last was Autumn
despite all the challenges we Face we
reduce business rates by an average of
10 percent so a conservative government
will always cut taxes when we can but we
won't run out of money we'll be
responsible with public finances because
businesses also so if you need stability
and if they're going to invest they need
to know that they've got a government
that is being sensible sound money
responsible with public it sounds you
know very Steady As She Goes
you know you're the chancellor right
this is probably the job you dreamed of
when you were a kid what's the vision
what's the big idea well I um when I was
young I took the decision not to get a
well-paid job in the city but to set up
my own business and that was the best
decision I ever took and I became
Chancellor because I want to help people
like me who had Big Dreams for the
future and I have Big Dreams for the
future of our country as well so that
means taking difficult decisions when
you have huge challenges like a pandemic
like an energy crisis it means being
responsible with public finances but
look at what's happened to this country
in the last 13 years we have built the
third biggest Tech economy in the world
after American China the biggest life
science sector in Europe where we
discovered one of the two big covert
vaccines one of the major covert
treatments the largest film and TV
industry in Europe we have got so many
exciting things happening in our country
country and I want to make sure that we
go from strength to strength you talk
about your vision there as a child you
know you were a radical on tax when you
ran for the leadership when you were
chair of the house select committee you
wanted to transform the NHS and now it
feels a bit like you know you're running
the economy as if you're Jeremy from
accounts well I think you have to wait
uh and see what I say on Wednesday
um but you know Jeremy the chancellor
will be responsible with public finances
I make absolutely no apology for that I
think families who want to know that
their money is safe need to know that
they have a responsible Chancellor and a
responsible conservative government but
what you will also see on Wednesday is
that we have a plan to tackle the
biggest problems we face as a country
whether it's a lack of investment
whether it's businesses not able to
recruit and we have a very exciting plan
for the future of our country that will
make us one of the most prosperous in
the world
um away from the budgets how come and
are you by the collapse of Silicon
Valley Bank UK
well I think the first thing to say is
the governor of the bank of England has
made it very clear there is no systemic
risk to our financial system so people
should be reassured on that basis but
there is a serious risk to our
technology and Life Sciences sectors
many of whom bank with this bank that
most people won't have heard of the
Silicon Valley Bank but it happens to
look after the money of some of our most
promising and exciting businesses and so
I want to reassure people I've been in
discussions over the weekend until late
last night with a Chancellor with the
Prime Minister the governor of the bank
of England many other people and we are
working at PACE on a solution we will
bring forward very soon plans to make
sure people are able to meet their cash
flow requirements pay their staff but
obviously what we want to do is to find
a longer term solution that minimizes or
even avoids completely losses to some of
our most promising companies could you
step in with taxpay's money to try and
Safeguard jobs I don't want to go into
what the solution is but what I will say
because people are worried about paying
their staff next week is we will come
forward with a solution that helps those
very very important companies with
things like payroll and their their cash
flow requirements but we also want to
put in place the longer term solution so
that their Futures are secure and how
quickly should we expect to see this
package well as I say we've been working
at PACE this only started to happen on
Friday we've been working at PACE uh
over the weekend through the night and
the Prime Minister and I and the
governor of the bank of England are
absolutely determined to do everything
we can to protect the future of these
very very important companies thank you
very much thank you